I think I still have a healthy amount of  awkwardness do yeah I think so uh-huh  I mean even the the attention that a  person gets as an actor it's I mean 30  years later it's still I get very uh you  know just my drennan gets prepped up and  I am nervous and feel nervous about what  um I don't know tripping okay you know  or just all the things that has you know  teenagers or you know going on on kind  of a date with the boy in high school or  something it's been saying likes you  yeah yeah you still worry about that or  think about that sometimes um well I  look at someone like I always use him as  an example like Will Smith uh-huh seems  to me like a perfect movie star he just  has charisma and people come up to him  and he just knows what to say Tom Hanks  is like this he knows how to make  conversation and you know and I just  felt hi how are you and kind of don't  know how to how to do this magical thing  that they do